talk to us champ the new ufc
heavyweight champion of the entire world
what's that seventh out seven billion
people what's the world's population
seven eight billion people
seven eight billion people you could
beat in the fair fight
the children the babies the girls that
has been on the planet yeah straight up
on the planet wow what a pleasure to be
introducing by
the big mike himself you know
tell us about the feeling of capturing
the champions oh man
it's awesome i remember being there uh
at that moment i can't explain
how it i mean i i mean you might know it
but i don't know how to explain that
did they show your hometown back home
yeah see
people have you seen it mike yeah it's
great
i i have even a better a better video uh
because like we have people there they
were filming and uh
when you see that you just go crazy they
were gonna when they lost their mind
nuts oh yeah because of the scene he
beat a great fighter he didn't beat a
tomato can uh bum he'd be the great
fighter you know he's great
to teach you before you even call him
great is almost understatement i mean
some things
you know grace of all time yeah like
there's argument for that
as well his stuff though
he's great yeah as tough as they come
because think about your first fight
like most of those shots you landed
would put anybody out yeah yeah he's
stuck with it
even the first round for this fight yeah
like he was
eating them and just look walk walk like
nothing
i knew he was in trouble when he
attempted that takedown
and you sprawled and brawled and then
got his back and seat belt and started
punching
oh it's about to be a long night for
steve bay france learned how to wrestle
oh yeah i was ready i'm like you know um
what happened in 2018 can't happen
anymore
like i have to be ready for this
that had to happen for this to happen
correct yep
that don't if that don't happen you
don't come here because i don't think
you're ready
that's true yeah that's true yeah
because is it fair to say like
if you would have won that first time i
don't know
because i you know you look at the
potential matchups you have in the
future which we'll get into
but i don't think you your legacy would
be cemented like it's going to be now
because that first fight you know you
you needed that
not just my legacy like uh even my fight
iq
my understanding of the game i mean he
was just like four years and a half
since when i get into mma so i had a lot
of
uh doubt like an answer question that i
was
i remember being there i was like asking
myself a lot of questions
yeah and i get there just after uh that
fight
right there i understood that i needed
this
i mean it wasn't like the best outcome
what i was
expected but i knew that uh from this
fight
i gonna go far i kind of like uh circle
the be
the uh fight and understand
like how he works now so i'm gonna be
ready for the next time
and to be honest i think like if he
wasn't about that fight
as you said i wouldn't be here now
because uh even if i would have win that
fight
later on down the road yes i would have
fallen because yeah
there was a lot of uh i'm sorry you
noticed that most fighters don't
understand no i
understood that like right away like i'm
like
okay he's sad that i lost but at the
meantime there's a lot of good thing
in this like i didn't have that
experience i have a lot of holes
in my game that i uh need to fill up and
that
allowed me to really understand what was
that and i'm like
okay from here i will gain that
experience
i have all the answer for the question
that i had
and uh you know moving on i'm gonna know
what i'm
putting myself into and that's why i
like walking into this fight
i knew like what what could possibly
happen
what could be the worst thing uh to
happen like
i was ready like okay doesn't matter
what happened
i will be here i will have the answer
for that
and you're also calm cool and collected
like like in previous fights
it always worked because i think your
longest fight for previously this like a
minute 12 or minute 11 so you're
starching dudes
and i was like man let's see if francis
has
you know if his iq's gotten higher
because you did rock stipe and i was go
here he goes and you stay calm
collected and just weathered you know
just you didn't rush in like an
inexperienced guy would do
exactly and that's what's scary to me
exactly that's terrifying
and that's what i'm talking about like
gaining experience from the last five
years because when you look
the last fight that's exactly what i did
like
after punch i was just walking through
him like
yep you know and you can't walk to a
champion like that
and i'm like no there's something then
after that fight i
went back washed his tips i'm like this
guy stuff
you can't just go there expect to just
walk through him he's not gonna fall you
know and uh for this time
everything was just about to be uh calm
like collect stay composed
take your time like you have 25 minutes
yes sir
you're gonna you have to manage that you
know if you go
crazy you're gonna lose your uh gas tank
in like
maybe one round that's what's steeping
what it wants what about what about the
on the other five rounds yeah you should
get there
so i'm like okay we have to spend like
equally stay
in the same gas in the same level yes
sir
and see how it plays out and uh yeah and
what's your wrestling coach's name
i dream i i strain that stream and
sometimes eric
or
dennis who yeah i think it's eric
because going into the fight
i said and i think he got to your coach
because he was like what is shob talking
about because i said
you know everyone's like france is so
much better friends so much better all i
said was
we don't know and it's not his fault but
he's been starching
everybody in those those four previous
fights his longest fight was a minute at
11 he starts everyone so i said
we the verdict's not out if his
wrestling's any better
that's all i said i think he was like
what the hell shob
and then after this fight i went holy
[ __ ]
his wrestling's way better they were
right you know what i'm saying
yeah and working to this fight i know
that there might be some
trap for stippy because like if he
he might watch he watched my fight again
uh
jesus and see the way that i rushed into
that fight
and he was expecting me to do the same
thing here i'm like this guy hasn't
changed
he's gonna do the same thing correct so
he was there like waiting for me yeah
i'm like
uh come on but then that's what he did
right he
he landed a decent shot and he was like
oh [ __ ] i got him
then he rushed in and then that's where
he clipped him with that left
hook yeah because even when he landed
that right hand
what went in in my mind was like damn
you're doing something wrong
because i knew we've been working on and
i knew that
the steepest step back her uh back right
is his first punch yep and that's what
he caught verdon with the first time
correct that's how he got it
yeah that's how he get his bed so when i
get that right hand on my face i'm like
damn you did something wrong
recom resettle calm down and uh
collect and then he just run he was just
running for me with his hand like this
like roses
like the roses he was doing what you did
against rosenstein he was like rushing
it was just like
[Laughter]
now that he's champ and obviously you
know france has a squad
now and one of the most famous guys on
the planet and you know this better than
anyone
is there is there things like traps you
should watch out for
like it's just because when you're
ranked number one it's just it's it's
different when you're champ
absolutely you know you know mike
there's traffic yeah but you know he's
this guy's definitely just going to stay
hungry
because he made because he learned from
the first fight with um
the champ yep right you learn from the
first fight you you know
you are him you can be beat you know you
came to that reality
before you know you thought you couldn't
be beaten you got beat by this guy
so that makes you even a better fight
fighter it should make you a better
fighter
should make you rise to the occasion
because you should know there's guys out
there
hungry just like you now guys who were
afraid of you when you were contenders
but now you're champion they're not
afraid of you no more they want to eat
you alive
isn't that something yeah everybody's
afraid of you when you're the contender
but when you're the champion that's
which change
they have to eat because you have the
bet
yeah when you you're the contender you
got the bag you get nothing for them
yeah but when you got the bag what the
rest when you're the child
that developed mean hungry people baby
[Music]
you